In the previous video, we explained how Project Kamp
works beyond the projects we normally show in our videos.
One of the most interestingtopics
is how we manage with food.
In Season 1, we set up the kitchen in a container.
In Season 2, we had some people coming to cook.
They started to organize our supplies.
andto rethink our way of eating.
And now, in Season 3, we have two cooks in the Kamp.
We are workingtowards a vision of
what could be a more sustainable kitchen.
Welcome to a new ProjectKamp update.
Welcome to the Project Kamp kitchen!
So, this year, we are with a lot of people at the Kamp.
At the moment, we are with about 25,
which means there a lot of stomachs to feed!
We would love todo it in the most sustainable way as possible!
But, we don't really know what that means...
So, westarted thinking and researching:
How to supply the food?
How to process the food?
Howto cook the food in the most sustainable way?
This year, we have two people at thekitchen.
So, it gives a bit more buffer for one to cook,
and the other one to do the research.
Is it by fate, or by accident?
I don't know. but we have two incredible German chefs,
whichis Timo and Paule.
Let me introduce them to you!
- Hey! I'm Paule!
I'm 29 years old, born and raisedin Berlin,
and I'm an absolute foodlover!
Back home, I focused mostly on teaching,
working in education, and playing footballand spikeball.
I came here to ProjectKamp to develop my passion for cooking,
while also trying to make people happy withthat!
I really like the social aspects about living in a community!
But, for now, my home base is still in Berlin.
When I come back, I want to positively influence mysurroundings,
and the things I have an impact on.
- Hi! I'm Timo!
I'm 38 years old.
I was born andI grew up in Germany,
but I have my roots in Turkey as well.
I enjoy being in nature, cooking,
exploring remote places with my van...
And, finding out more about myself,
through meditation andother means.
Until last year, I was working as an IT consultant.
I joined Project Kamp to see what it's like.
To both work as a chef, and live with other people
that have an interest insustainability.
While it's still unclear what I'll do next,
I can say that I'm very happy beinghere and exploring the surroundings.
So, now that you know our chefs, we can start the journey
intofinding out how to make a sustainable kitchen.
- Hi! Good morning!
It's seven in the morning,
and we are preparing breakfast right now.
Come, I'll show you!
For breakfast, we normally havesome porridge,
which Ale is preparing right now.
Here you can seeour toppings: a little bit of cacao, cinnamon...
You can also see a wonderful self-madebread!
In the back, you also see our coffee.
It's not the most sustainable product, but...
We try our best with most of the products we have.
The coffee is still here!
So, right now, I'm preparing some bruschetta for the breakfast,
because people are goingcrazy for that!
It's some tomatoes, basil, and garlic,
mixed up with some oil and vinegar.
Here, we have some nice basil,
and now I'm gonnaslap it to release the oils.
- Bad basil!
You decide to make bruschettathat everyone eats with bread,
so now weare completely out of bread...
- I justwant to make people happy you know!
I don't prepare breakfast every day!
I just doit on Thursdays.
Everyone has just one day to clean basically, and set up breakfast.
Then,I have to cook every other day nevertheless, but yeah...
Here, we have our hot water.
Our soft coffeein a French press.
Espresso from thermal pour flask.
We have our kettle which we try to use as often as possible.
Also for cooking in general, to not use that much gas.
Energywise, we alwayshave to check it in the morning.
As you can see, we have 75% of battery,
but we also cansee that it's gonna be a sunny day
So, we can use our toaster instead,
because the mostpeople like to toast their bread.
If we don't have the energy capacity for it,
we toast it in apan with gas, but we want to use the toaster more.
Pretty okay!
The porridge, the toppings for theporridge,
a lot of nice fruit we have right now, which is quite nice...
more melon, our bread, some hummus,
some bruschetta, and peanut butter and jam.
The bread is already half gone,
becausepeople start to eat it all day long!
- No, no! It's the people eating bread in the morning!
I eat the same bread all the time!
- You need energy!
Now, we're going to actually have alook at the veggies.
And, at the suppliers, which we're getting them from.
So, let me take you there!
We do two shopping trips each week with this car.
We still would like to incorporate that in our data,
like taking the consumption of thecar.
Calculate what the CO2-footprint of the cargo
is going these kilometers each week.
Wecan see how much it is,
in relation to the food we're getting.
Maybe, we can change somethingaround,
like reducing the number of shopping trips.
We're, of course, trying to get as much food
from our neighboring farms and shops.
It's 10 to 15 minutes in each direction,
so nothing is toofar away.
We actually have the the power
to support some projects here locally.
With our buying powerfor veggies and other food items,
that we can get from the shops.
You could say that all the allthe people are supporting us financially...
Or, just by watching the videos,
you are also supportingthese local communities here and shops.
All right!
So, welcome to Nuno's farm!
Nuno is one of our main suppliers.
He grows veggies in a regenerative way,
and this is just the land where he's growing them.
There he is!
- Hey! How are you?
I'm good! How are you?
- Yeah, I am good!
So, Istarted farming four years ago.
In 2019, which was just two years after the big fire,
that happened in thisregion.
It's when almost everything burned down.
I do agro ecology.
So, behind the organic certificator,
we also do work on the system as a whole.
Like, every being can come to eat.
And then, what remains, because the soil
produces enough for everyone, we eat and we sell.
- Nuno does regenerative farming.
That means he doesn't use any chemical fertilizers.
He justfollows natural processes that build fertile soil.
- The nature always tends to regenerate itself.
So, if you abandon the land, it will regenerate.
We just try to do these kind of processes,
but now we select what we want to let grow.
It creates more productivity,
and more different food in the samespace!
But, it's always more work.
- We've researched that, so far, it's one of the biggest factors
in the CO2-emissions of veggies.
The type of land usage, like we have here,
has a negative CO2-footprint, depending on the crop that is growing.
You want one, Javi?
- Okay!
A nice strawberry!
Wow!
And here, altogether: the basilwith strawberries,
that you say aredelicious, with onions, with kale...
Therewere even spring onions here in the middle!
So, we have already here some thingsharvested.
Let's save them from the sun.
All of this is your food, and then we will get
something that has been missing.
Okay, the car is loaded.
Thankyou Nuno!
- You're welcome!
I'll see you next week!
Now, we're heading to Tata.
A zerowaste bulkshop in a town nearby.
We're in the Tata Bulkshop!
We just didour shopping!
We got some big bags of whole grain flour
and all the white flour.
We havesome pasta, soy chunks...
We usually bring some of our glasses here.
Some blueberries, shiitake mushrooms,
apple vinegar, jams that we get from here...
We're very happy that this shop exists here!
About the two wonderful people, who had the idea
to found the shop, are Tiago and Daniela.
- Yeah, we decided to open this zero-waste/bulkstore,
because we wanted to really let go on plastic.
Also, it creates a more sustainable living,
and offer that to the people near us.
In the main city,there's a like three or four now.
Back then, there were zero,
and Daniela and I were still the only ones!
We opened two years ago, in a month or so.
We were like: ''Oh my God! Maybe this is not gonnawork!''
Fortunately, we're still here!
- The last stop of our shopping tripis Ecoseiva, an organic farm.
We source from them as well by getting someveggies,
that we don't get from Nuno.
Maybe six or so?
So, after our shopping trip,
we head intoour storage container we finished in aprevious update.
Let me show you!
here, in thefirst part, we have General Help's tools.
In the back, we both have on the left
the workspace storage, and here's our new foodstorage.
this here enables us to have mainlymore space in the kitchen, for just working there to be honest
because it was getting quite
tight
But, it also enables us to buy bigger quantities,
and store bigger quantities.
We have some legumes, lentils, soybeans, couscous...
We've got a big barrel of oats and sugar,
flax seeds, sunflower seeds, soya granulate...
At some point, in this cacao barrel,
there was about 25 kilos.
Now, there's not so much left as you can see.
Some washing powder that we also buy inbulk at Tata.
Some reusable packaging, like these glass jars,
which were filling up the kitchen before.
The soap we're using, or the baking soda...
As you can see, the storage space gives us a lot
of new options to potentially reduce our carbon footprint.
Maybe, even cater to more people!
If youhave any ideas on what we can do with it,
please feel free to leave a comment!
For us, it's stillvery new.
We only have it for a couple of weeks.
But, for now, we leave this space,
and we head tothe kitchen to cook the lunch for today.
We want to show you around the kitchena bit.
There's a whole video on how this kitchen
has been built by One Army.
You can check it out in the link below.
The first thing you see when you enterthe kitchen
might be the queue for the washing machine.
This one can be a bit noisy sometimes,
but it's not the worst thing in Kamp.
A small storage cabinet here.
We have some seeds and kernels,
and over here some nuts.
A lot of the goods, like rice and pasta
This is our big fridge!
It has a lot of storage options,
which is very nice, but it can get crowded sometimes.
As you can see right now.
A whole lot of fresh veggies in the drawers
And then, usually, it's some leftover fruit.
A little wine, some beer, then some salad.
The pizza boxes are down there.
Unfortunately, we are gettingmold in the fridge,
and it gets a bit humid inside...
We don't really have a good idea yet on how totackle that.
So maybe if you have something,
please comment, or let us know somewhere!
Usually, we have a drying rack here.
So, when stuff is washed up, and there is usually
quite the mountain formingduring the cooking.
Here, we have a beautiful oven.
It's not working as an oven,
because we don'thave three-phase electricity...
We use it for storage of some dry stuff.
Like, onions, potatoes, pumpkinsas you can see back there.
Here are our beauties!
All the pans and woks, and they are cast iron.
We try to takegood care of them as well like,
when after we've used them, we put some oil in.
We, of course,never use soap to wash them.
We're cooking for almost 25 people right now.
Most of it we fit.
If shove comes to push, we have the very big one up here!
Because we don't have too much time leftuntil lunch,
we should get into the cooking.
Paule already started!
- I think we're good in time, butwe should start now!
A vegan red thai curry, which should have some nice heat.
Timo has a differentdifferent style of cooking than me.
But, I think it fits perfectly!
- It's a lot of fun together!
Yep!
- It doesn't feel like work much...
If that's what you say at least!
- German joke!
Unfortunately, you want to leave me.
I'mpretty sad about that...
- It's really hard to go,
but I also have a lot of nice things to go to, so...
I don't know how the next one will be.
There is a lot of people in the group also leaving and coming,
so you have to get used to a bit of change.
It's okay for coconut milk, yeah?
It's kind of thick!
We'rekind of making it ourselves,
with sunflower kernels, coconut oil, and water.
It works quite wellinstead of buying all these coconut milk cans.
So, now, we've prepared the food on the counter!
It's ready for the people to load their plates!
Paule, do you want to sound the horn,
for the last meal here?
- Yes! Yes, yes!
That means that the meal is ready!
Wealso synced it to the office, with our walkie-talkie.
Now, at some point, people will come here and eat!
It should be thai red curry, but it's brown.
I'm late for lunch!
After the cooking is done, the leftovers go intothe fridge,
and food scraps go into the compost.
At the moment, we use it mainly as soilfor our kitchen garden.
After resting a bit, Paule will show you around.
So, besides oursuppliers we already showed you,
we also grow a little bit of things in our little garden.
Here, we got a little bit of lemongrass for teas,
and some rosemary, which is a littlebit burnt.
But, still, it's working out!
Some thyme down here, and also some wildmint,
which there is a lot of.
We also have some fruit trees!
For example, thispeach tree was planted in the first season!
As you can see right now, it's full of ripe fruits,
and ants, but it's some really delicious fruit!
A fig tree, which already gave some nice fruits.
Also, they will take some more time to be edible and ripe.
An avocado tree!
It's quite healthy right now,but also it will take some years to get some fruit and some nice avocados out of that.
An almond tree we planted.
The same as the avocado: it's just too young to give some nuts.
but it's hereand healthy
Now, I'm going to show you our little experimental garden.
Just for fun!
You can see wehave some tomatoes here,
and some basil in between.
Also, some unexpected, but nice guests,
like thiscucumber/courgette/pumpkin family thing.
This came from the compost actually!
For now, it's justa small scale.
We're just experimenting and having some fun!
But also, we're getting supplied by our neighbors a little bit
for harvesting or just helping them.
Here, you can see some nicefootage of the latest potato harvest.
I'm doing very well!
But, nomatter how hard I try, I always break some
and miss some, so it's really difficult.
After helping the neighbors with the potato harvest,
we got a gift, which is a big bag of huge, nicepotatoes!
Today, as we are also heating theoven for baking our bread...
We decided to make baked potatoes basically with some toppings!
Tim was already preparing that.
An onion tomato salad here.
Our self-made picklesright now...
And, in the back, you can see chickpeas boiling.
With that, we are going to do hummus,
and also maybe roast some of the chickpeas in the oven.
They're still hot!
Just put itin here.
Now, it's quite smooth!
The spices will go through it later.
Also, withsome toppings.
Now, we're gonna cook the potatoes,
before putting it into the oven.
Because,we are not really sure how high
the temperature should be...
If it's enough for these huge potatoesto cook.
We also don't want to peel them,
but cook them as a whole, to have better taste.
Basically, a better consistency in the middle.
Now, let's see how the potatoes are doing
They're still quite hard.
It was expectable...
A bit of salt just, and just pour some oil.
They are still really hot!
So, now, I'm gonna takethat to the pizza hut.
As you can see, the bread team is already taking out the bread.
The oven isstill quite hot!
It's really hot.
about 300 degrees in the back.
250in the middle, which is perfect.
We will do with another batch too!
Now, we are going to check,
if the potatoes arealready done.
We have the second batch also in.
Let's show it to you!
That's basically how it should be, I guess?
It is done!
- It's food time!
So, now you'veseen what we do on a daily basis in
andaround the kitchen, here at Project Kamp.
But,we're also trying to keep on researching,
and improve further on.
We're looking a bit more intothe data.
I can show you some things here.
So, here you can see our receipt data in detail
Don't worry -- I'll try not to bore you with all these numbers.
Just to give you an idea:
We gatheredall the food and corresponding prices amounts,
and CO2-equivalents in a time frame of about 11weeks.
In this 11-week time frame, we tracked more than 1.1 tons of food.
The colorful pie chart shows how much variety we have
in terms of the ingredients we're using.
After matching the food weconsumed
with the environmental impact data from two studies...
We arrived at a total about 2.8 tons
of CO2-equivalence we emitted.
It was interesting to see that although we only
consumed 17kilograms of coffee...
It is by far the biggest slice of the emissions pie at 17%.
We alsofound out that our trips to the shops and the farms
are a considerable part of our emissions around 7%.
With the emissions of all the 1.1 tons of food,
we got we could have gottenonly 28 kilograms of beef!
It has a comparable environmental impact,
but it's almost 40 times lessin volume.
I also doubt we would have been able
to keep the group fed with it!
Even though there arestill limitations of
our research and the data we used...
It's nice seeing that our projectedyearly emissions
are almost three times less than the average person!
But, there is always room to improve.
So, one challenge we're facing right now,
after having done this research:
Whatdo we do with the resource intensive goods we are consuming?
This is mostly coffee and cheese.
It'skind of a sensitive topic to many people,
if you take away the the coffee, for example in themornings.
I'm not sure if that would work out so well...
So, for now, I leave you.
If you like whatyou see,
you can support us on Patreon.
You could also see the next video without ads,
aboutthe clearing of the top rock area, already now!
If not, you can subscribe to our channel!
Thanksfor watching, and see you in the next update!